each of us understands what symptoms
have been identified
but only now do we start to understand
that there is also a long covid
between five and fifty percent of people
struggle with this disease
for much longer than expected people who
have been treated at our hospital
they are coming back and these
situations are becoming even more common
than simple i got sick cases this is
very worrying
just like house md precisely
incomprehensible symptoms
everything is just like in that series
i thought that i was cured and
everything would return to normal
but unfortunately this was not the case
i started choking
felt bad and had to call a doctor again
i realized that i couldn't walk
more than 100 to 150 meters i was
getting tired immediately
and i would get a burning feeling in my
chest
it would be logical if complications
after covert occurred in the most severe
cases
of patients who lie like this in
intensive care on ventilators
but in fact this is not the case the
majority of people with the so-called
covid tail
or long coved are young people who've
never been in
intensive care and moreover have not
even consulted doctors about coving
i did not have any fever or cough at all
then i started to cough up blood and i
got a very severe pain in my legs
symptoms were ending other was starting
headaches and even congestion in my
chest despite no damage to my lungs
it was just endless it is as if you are
sick with something but
what exactly nobody can tell
small thrombosis occur in the vessels of
the brain little hemorrhages
all this becomes evident by a very
different symptoms sometimes rather
obvious and sometimes not
a headache is something understandable
and this is not due to intoxication
but due to covid micro bleeding and
swelling
massive weakness is also what everyone
describes and what is completely unusual
for other diseases
visual and hearing impairment dreams
become weird even hallucinogenic
and tachycardia can be terrible and
completely inexplicable
even young people can have it even young
people who do not have any heart
pathologies
they go through an ecg an echo but
doctors find nothing
[Music]
all this made us realize that this is
damage to the central nervous system
so the brain sends you some kind of a
signal stay
sick yes something like this
every day we see more and more patients
for whom kovid did not
end with them leaving the hospital
sometimes the consequences last for
months
and how long it will last is completely
incomprehensible
the most important thing here is not to
miss the moment
and see a doctor in time
you